for all the global attention this was
about a grieving family saying goodbye a
life ended so publicly so brutally in
death George Floyd was honored in the
place he called home
a moment of intensity for those who knew
him best in what was a celebration of
life now you know what that means that
means foot stopping toe tapping
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jedi no punches gonna
yes it will
[Applause]
[Music]
god bless applause but there was no
escaping his death is now a political
issue I can't turn away we must not turn
away we cannot leave this moment
thinking we can once again turn away
from racism that stings that our very
soul even here the feeling of injustice
was real Jorge floored was not
expendable this is why we are here
his crime was that he was born black and
for Jorge Floyd's family the hurt thank
God forgive me give me my own personal
Superman bless you
[Applause]
no more hate Christ please someone said
make America great again but when has
America ever been great the eulogy came
from an icon of the civil rights
movement if four blacks had done to one
way if four black cops had done to one
way what was done to Jorge they would
send them to jail and until we know the
price for black life is the same as the
price for white life we're gonna keep
coming back to these situations over and
over again
it was a service that reflected the
outrage and the sense of a movement
created George Floyd was laid to rest
next to his mother a life ended but a
legacy that may change the course of
history